bonjour à tous au mois d'avril prochain
le gouvernement doit présenter son
nouveau projet de loi sur la
décentralisation
un texte qui vise à clarifier les
compétences entre les régions et les
départements
dans ce cadre la commission de la
culture du sénat organise ce matin une
table ronde portant sur la
décentralisation culturelle
objectif de cette table ronde il a
d'abord effectué un bilan de la
décentralisation culturelle depuis les
années 80 mais également envisager les
perspectives de l'offre artistique
territoriale
pour cela les membres de la commission
auditionne des acteurs de la culture
mais aussi des représentants de
l'administration culturelle dans les
territoires tout de suite on va voir
cette table ronde en salle clémenceau
bien mesdames et messieurs mes chers
collègues
merci de votre présence je suis heureuse
que nous soyons réunis ce matin pour
aborder la question de la
décentralisation culturelle
je salue la présence des acteurs de la
culture venue dans le public pour
assister à nos débats et je précise
d'ailleurs qu'un courrier a été envoyé
aux syndicats représentant différents
acteurs et personnels pour leur signaler
qu aujourd'hui nous débattons sous une
forme mais que nous collectons leur
contribution et que nous les entendrons
dans un deuxième temps quand arrivera la
loi cette mobilisation montre que le
sujet que nous allons traiter primordial
dans le contexte législatif actuel
depuis les années 80 la logique de
décentralisation culturelle fut celle
d'un exercice conjoint d'une compétence
générale par chacun des niveaux de
collectivités publiques par opposition à
la logique du transfert de blocs de
compétences exclusif la loi de
décentralisation de 82 83 ont consacré
la clause de compétence générale
considère à la fois comme une forme
d'expression du principe constitutionnel
de libre administration des
collectivités territoriales et
comme la référence de la gouvernance des
politiques publiques culturelles
cette organisation a permis aux
collectivités d'affirmer progressivement
leur poids et leur place incontournable
en termes de financement se rappelle que
70 % des dépenses culturelles sont
réalisés par les collectivités mais
également à travers l'exercice de
compétences privilégiée dans le cadre
d'une politique partenariale entre
l'état et les collectivités
je pense par exemple aux archives ou à
la lecture publique
la loi du 13 août 2004 relative aux
libertés et responsabilités locales a
consacré une nouvelle étape notable ans
dans le domaine de la politique
patrimoniale avec le transfert de
propriété de 65 monuments historiques de
l'état à des régions départements ou
communes
cette loi également tenté de clarifier
le rôle de chaque collectivité publique
dans l'organisation des compétences dans
le domaine des enseignements artistiques
le chemin n'a pas abouti parallèlement
les établissement public de coopération
culturelle ont vu le jour à l'initiative
d'un sénateur de notre commission ivan
renar et se sont multipliés pour
proposer une main mode de coopération
souple et originale entre collectivités
et dans la majorité des cas avec l'état
revenons sur la loi du 16 décembre 2010
de réforme des collectivités
territoriales qui avait supprimé la
clause de compétence générale des
départements et des régions
à compter du 1er janvier 2015 mais grâce
à des amendements vigoureusement défendu
la loi avait maintenu une compétence
partagée dans le domaine de la culture
l'article 1er de la loi du 27 janvier
2014 de modernisation de l'action
publique territoriale et d'affirmation
des métropoles dit
ma femme a introduit un nouvel article
dans le code général des collectivités
territoriales
cet article prévoit que ouvrez les
guillemets sauf lorsque sont en cause
des intérêts nationaux
l'état peut déléguer par convention à
une collectivité territoriale ou un
établissement public de coopération
intercommunale à fiscalité propre qui en
fait la demande
l'exercice de certaines de ses
compétences
dernier événement en date le président
de la république a récemment annoncé la
nécessité d'une clarification strict des
compétences entre collectivités
un projet de loi est actuellement en
cours de rédaction pour être soumis à
l'examen du parlement dès le mois de mai
prochain
dans un tel contexte il m'a paru
nécessaire de prendre le temps de la
réflexion pour que soit abordé en
profondeur et hors de toute polémique la
question de la décentralisation
culturelle dont les acteurs principaux
n'ont pas été aux premières loges des
débats jusqu'à maintenant je vous
proposerai ainsi d'évoquer chacun
quelques observations sur le bilan de la
décentralisation culturelle depuis 1981
en mettant en évidence des réussites ou
d'éventuels dysfonctionnements observés
sur le terrain les débats suscités par
l'article 1er de la loi
ma femme ainsi que par la mise en oeuvre
du pacte d'avenir pour la bretagne
puisque nous accueillons aujourd'hui le
vice président du conseil régional de
bretagne en charge de la culture
nous parlerons sans doute des questions
que posent les personnels des drac qui
s'émeuvent dans la presse et par
courrier de leur devenir
enfin parce que la culture n'est pas une
marchandise et parce que le parlement ne
confonds pas les intérêts sectoriels et
l'intérêt général
au delà de la question des compétences
ou des perspectives d'évolution de
l'offre artistique territoriale et des
modalités de son financement
il nous faut préciser le sens et
l'ambition que nous donnons à l'action
publique pour favoriser le développement
social et culturel de chacun sur le
territoire où qu'ils soient et quels que
soient son vécu propre
merci aux rédacteurs du manifeste pour
les produits de haute nécessité qui cite
au delà du boire survivre manger le
prosaïque l'aspiration un épanouissement
de soi
la houle a dit nourriture et de dignité
d'honneur de musique de chants de sports
de danses de lectures de philosophie de
spiritualité d'amour de temps libre
affecté à l'accomplissement du grand
désir intime
en clair le poétique de cela nous devons
être garant je proposerai à chaque
intervenant au groupe d'intervenants
puisque certains sont venus en binôme de
présenter son ou leur point de vue
pendant une dizaine de minutes afin de
préserver un temps suffisant pour les
débats avec les membres de la commission
de la culture de l'éducation et de la
communication
notre table ronde ne constitue bien sûr
qu'une première étape très anticipée
d'une réflexion globale que nous
poursuivrons dans les prochains mois au
sein de la commission et au sein du
parlement bien je vous propose de vous
entendre
alors on va commencer par ceux qui ont
fait parler les bretons bien qu'il y à
d'autres représentants de la bretagne
nous allons attendre jean michel le
boulanger qui est vice président chargé
de la culture et des pratiques
culturelles et thierry le nédic qui est
directeur de la culture au conseil
régional de bretagne messieurs vous avez
la parole
merci madame la présidente je rebondis
sur une phrase que vous venez de formule
et les débats de ce matin concernent le
sens et l'ambition de l'action publique
et c'est la kz2 mon propos et la kz2 la
position que le conseil régional de
bretagne tentent de définir depuis
quelques semaines autour de ceux que
vous avez cités à savoir le pacte
d'avenir et cette fameuse phrase sur une
éventuelle délégation de compétence dont
le périmètre reste à définir et sur
lequel évidemment nous travaillons
je veux rappeler quatre ou cinq éléments
de contexte qui illustre la toile de
fond devant laquelle nous nous
travaillons
premier élément de contexte c'est que
effectivement il ya une grande
singularité en région bretagne dans le
domaine de la vitalité culturelle dans
toutes les esthétiques et dans tous les
domaines
cette vitalité culturelle se mesure à
travers un certain nombre d'indicateurs
que le ministère de la culture maîtrisé
que nous avons évidemment à disposition
bref une vraie vitalité dans tous les
secteurs
deuxième point c'est une vraie
singularité et cette singularité
nécessite de s'y arrêter juste en en
quelques instants
il se trouve et c'est une originalité de
l'histoire c'est une originalité des
pratiques culturelles depuis des
décennies et des décennies en bretagne
les cultures populaires restent
extrêmement vivace et elle reste mêlée à
la création c'est à dire que
contrairement à d'autres régions en
europe ce que l'on peut appeler les
cultures populaires ne se sont pas
folkloriser elles ont toujours été liés
à la création elles le sont aujourd'hui
encore c'est pourquoi je n'emploie
jamais l'expression de culture bretonne
je ne sais pas ce que c'est nous avons
des
l'ensemble musique pour nous avons des
ensembles de danse en bretagne qui
travaille avec des musiciens
contemporains avec des chorégraphes
contemporains et il est très difficile
de savoir dans quelle case ils sont et
musique populaire musique savante
culture populaire culture savante ça ne
fait cas voilà et là il ya une vraie
singularité parce que ça s'accompagne de
pratiques amateurs et professionnels
c'est à dire que la dissociation entre
les professionnels et les pratiques
amateurs est aussi extrêmement difficile
à faire à partir du moment où beaucoup
de cultures populaires sont portés par
des tissus amateurs mais qu'il travaille
en permanence dans des créations avec
des professionnels on va dire donc là il
ya une singularité sur laquelle on est
obligé de s'arrêter un petit peu c'est
légal dignité des formes de culture
c'est ce qui forment la base des
politiques culturelles que nous
entendons développer et je suis très
heureux de le dire ici dans une salle
qui s'appelle clemenceau connaissant un
petit peu l'histoire et sachant combien
clemenceau s'est battu pour légal
dignité des civilisations en particulier
dans un de ses plus grands discours où
il le s'opposait à la colonisation de la
fin du 19e siècle qui était très
verticale et qui posait une hiérarchie
entre les civilisations les formes de
culture
ça c'est le deuxième point les grande
singularité troisième point c'est les
mutations en cours que vous connaissez
mieux que moi
les mutations en cours qui se traduisent
par sur l'allée base que vous indiquiez
tout à l'heure madame la présidente des
débats ce qui ce qui bouge les lignes
bougent
les difficultés budgétaires de
nombreuses collectivités territoriales
le budget de l'état le budget des
conseils généraux contrats pour des
raisons fiscales que nous connaissons
les lignes bougent et il y à des
mutations qui pose de grandes
difficultés pour de nombreux acteurs ça
grésille
bien et ça gêne un peu via un micro qui
s'affolent alors oui quand même
alors je vais continuer je suis vraiment
désolé ce grésillement si les postes de
régulation dans les cabines peuvent
faire quelque chose
l'évocation des mânes de clemenceau a
manifestement quelques influences dans
la salle ça déclenche le phénomène
intempestifs voilà on débranche allez-y
alors je continue donc
autre point de de toile de fond ce qui
nous rapproche directement du sujet
chacun connaît autour de la table les
vieilles voulons très volonté
décentralisatrice de la bretagne en
général et de la région bretagne en
particulier
c'est un débat très très ancien qui a
plus d'un siècle qui fait que nous
pensons régulièrement en bretagne à rené
pleven est né à tous les combats qui
avait été menée par rené plein dans les
années 50 et 60
et vous savez que depuis une vingtaine
d'années majorité après majorité il y a
eu et souvent de manière totalement
unanime d'ailleurs des volonté
décentralisatrice affiché en bretagne
c'est un élément de la toile de fond
c'est aussi notre héritage et puis on en
arrive avec tous ces différents éléments
là à penser que le moment ce moment de
difficulté économique et financière pour
de nombreux acteurs et pour de
nombreuses collectivités ce moment et
vraisemblablement propice pour que la
bretagne joue le rôle d'un laboratoire
d'une nouvelle gouvernance des
politiques culturelles
pourquoi il nous semble que la bretagne
pourrait jouer ce rôle pour que la crise
soit une opportunité en fait pour
déboucher sur de nouvelles gouvernances
parce que je crois qu'on a des atouts
tout ce que je viens de dire en matière
de vitalité en matière de singularité en
matière de relation
étroite que la région avec la drac c'est
un élément important du dossier pour
nous nous avons une habitude de travail
en commun qui est extrêmement régulière
il n'y a pas de dossier qu'il ne soit
pas concertés discuter la relation est
quasi quotidiennes avec les services de
la drac nous avons également des
relations très étroites nous région avec
évidemment les départements et les
villes ces relations semaine en
bilatérales ces relations ce même de
manière plus globale et avec les
départements en particulier il y a
régulièrement des tables rondes où nous
travaillons à cinq régions plus les
quatre départements sur les grandes
problématiques auxquelles nous nous
confrontons ce qui veut dire qu'il ya
une pratique du travail en commun qui ne
naît pas d'une volonté nouvelle de
conférences territoriales mais qui
s'enracine déjà dans une véritable
histoire
et puis il y a une autre pratique et
madeleine louarn ici présentes à un
autre titre pourrait avec ses
responsabilités de créatrice on va dire
en parler en attester nous avons une
habitude de co-construction avec les
acteurs de la vitalité culturelle et
c'est donc sur cette base de réseaux
d'habitude de travail en commun et de
co-construction que nous avons envisagé
de proposer de discuter à l'état non pas
qu'il y ait moins d'état mais qu'il y
ait mieux d'état ce qui se traduirait et
se traduira c'est dans le cadre du pacte
d'avenir par non pas un transfert de
compétence mais par une délégation de
compétence sur un périmètre qui reste à
définir et sur la base d'une convention
fixant des grands objectifs partagés de
politiques publiques entre l'état et la
région en lien étroit évidemment dans le
prolongement de la loi avec l'ensemble
des autres collectivités territoriales
pour nous à ce moment ci se dire au 13
décembre signature du pacte d'avenir 16
décembre vote de la loi et les
perspectives qui s'ouvrent pour nous
l'état d'esprit est très simple je veux
leur dire parce que comme vous le disiez
madame la présidente on a beaucoup parlé
de la bretagne depuis quelques mois
pas tous
pour c'est un jugement de valeur en bien
mais on a beaucoup parlé de la bretagne
je veux rappeler que pour nous
conseiller régional de bretagne
la proximité n'est pas une vertu la
proximité peut offrir des facilités de
réseaux de travail en commun mais la
proximité n'est pas une vertu c'est pas
parce que le pouvoir est proche
il est équitable mais al'inverse
l'éloignement n'est pas une vertu non
plus ce n'est pas parce que le pouvoir
est lointain qu'il est par définition
équitable ce qui fait que j'ai tendance
à réagir parfois quand je lis dans la
presse que la proximité engendre le
copinage et que l'éloignement engendre
une position plus éthiques
c'est discutable la vertu n'est ni d'un
côté ni de l'autre c'est une question de
conscience de travail des tic
je disais tout à l'heure c'est un
premier élément mais en ce qui nous
concerne nous ne pensons pas que la
proximité soit une vertu en tout état de
cause
deuxième élément la décentralisation ne
peut jamais être la victoire de l'un sur
l'autre
c'est à dire qu'une décentralisation
réussie c'est la victoire de l'esprit
public du service public de l'argent
public ce n'est pas la victoire de la
région sur l'état ce n'est pas la
victoire d'une métropole sur un
département ce n'est pas la victoire de
la région sur les départements c'est la
victoire de l'esprit public défini
autour d'une table où l'ensemble des
partenaires sont réunis c'est
l'efficacité du mieux et an ou deux le
plutôt que du moins d'état évidemment et
on en arrive là donc ces rappels de deux
positions de principe étant défini est
en pause et on en arrive là la
co-construction que nous engageons
actuellement et nous nous mettons dans
les pas du président de la république et
du premier ministre pour regarder où il
y à double et il se trouve que je peux
prendre un exemple et je terminerai par
là pour me rapprocher des 10 minutes et
du zoom final il y a dans l'organisation
de l'état déconcentré et de la région il
ya des doublons je prends un exemple
très concret sur lequel nous travaillons
actuellement c'est les politiques de
cinéma la politique de cinéma est menée
au niveau national par le cnc la
politique du cinéma ou de l'audiovisuel
peut être porté par la région c'est le
cas de la région bretagne y investissant
5 millions d'euros par an
il se trouve qu'au niveau de la drac
donc dans les services déconcentrés il y
a également un service cinéma et
audiovisuel qui a un budget de 150 mille
euros par an et deux agents nous nous
avons un budget de 5 millions d'euros
par an et trois agents et demi qui